77 minutes you know a lot of those kids
who could have still been alive
[Music]
no
it's like hercules they could've just
went in
[Music]
whenever they heard the gunshots
two guys went back
they ran back and they could have just
ran in there
but they didn't what did that make you
feel like
[Music]
she
is amazing anjali looked
up to annabelle a lot she needs her
sister it's hard that she's gonna have
to
enter
the following grades without her sister
[Music]
i just don't feel safe sending them to
school
[Music]
what would you like to see that they do
in the school that they haven't it's
the accountability part all those cops
all those school cops you know let's get
rid of them i say let's get some people
that are very highly trained
[Music]
what would you like to hear or see from
your governor special session called a
special session you know let's let's get
that age limit up you know well let's
take a step we'll take a step
21 you know if that
that kid weren't able to get that gun so
easy
you know we'd have a lot of those kids
still here